it's the first time ever uh the met
office has issued a red weather warning
in our capital uh city over the last few
days uh we've got together and stood up
again the uh strategic coordinating
group and the met office are a key
partner in that group the met office and
our first responders are worried about
as a consequence of winds up to 80 miles
per hour
uh but you could have a situation where
trees are falling down where there's
debris flying around roof tiles
garden furniture scaffolding
another debris and that leading to the
potential of real harm to londoners so
the message to londoners is whilst the
net office has the red weather warning
stay indoors a storm units is the worst
storm we've faced in three decades it's
really important we don't inadvertently
put ourselves in harm's way by being
outdoors
now of course this red weather warning
has been in place for coming up to two
hours in london in the southeast of
england uh several more hours here in
the south west uh it does mean that
there is a danger to life are there any
reports of incidents so far
in london i was in touch with the fire
commissioner recently and thankfully uh
london has appeared to be following the
adviser by and large uh we have we are
having reports of trees falling over the
royal parks have uh closed all uh the
parks they're responsible for
uh we've also had all the tourist
attractions that have been closed for
the day there are no flights from the
city airport flights from heathrow and
catholic have been uh delayed so i think
us are on the side of the side of
caution hopefully
it leads to legislation whether on
uh examples of people being injured or
even worse losing their lives it will be
the case so even though you're indoors
in london looking out you may think the
skies are blue it doesn't appear too
blasphemy or too windy if you go
outdoors you can be caught short and
what you don't want to do is to be in
the receiving end of you know flying
roof tiles scaffolding and the like
now the army is on standby to help out
if needed uh today is this something you
anticipate will happen
no i'm keeping i'm keeping everything
crossed uh the we've got a really good
system in uh london the first responders
the
fire brigade police service the abilene
service
but also the utility companies the royal
parks councils we're all working really
closely together we have real-time
information what's happening in our city
and i think that's planning for this
because the net office tipped us off
means that we're in a good place now
but as you've said there are plans in
place should things get worse we don't
think they will the med office think the
weather should get easier uh this
afternoon we may be able to move to
amber
uh if the met office uh uh i think it's
right to do so it will still be
advisable to stay indoors
uh we are lucky this week is half term
seven got children out about going to
school coming back from school and so as
long as there is a red notice staying
doors and i'll encourage people to of
course continue watching the sky news
but keep an eye out on the website start
the bet office as well to see what
they're advising
now as you would expect in a straw
mysterious is this there is significant
disruption to travel uh we've seen
images this morning of some rather shaky
aircraft trying to
come in to learn that some of the
capitals airports what would be your
advice to the airlines and travel
industry today
so so although the airports are open the
flights have paused city airport will
have no flights today
heathrow and gatwick are delaying
flights going out so if you've got a
flight please check on their relevant
websites before you go out trains coming
into london and out of london have been
uh suspended we are having examples and
stories of some of our buses that are
running at some of our tubes and out of
london where there's uh their service
trains having a disruption because of
branches falling or trees falling and
that's why the best advice is stay
indoors
check you know with obviously sky news
but also websites if you've got travel
plans if you do have to leave your home
building extra time and be extra
vigilant and extra careful if you leave
your home
now of course storm eunice will have
passed by the end of the day what we
don't yet know is what destruction it
will leave behind uh from what you're
seeing now uh
nearly an hour well nearly two hours
into uh this red warning in london how
do you think the capital will fare
so far so good the big thing we're
worried about is obviously the debris
flying around
uh and that's why if people have you
know loose garden furniture or or bins
bring the bin or use a garden shed or
whatever you can to keep keep them close
so don't get blown uh away there will
need to be a cleanup operation clearly
thankfully uh we've had no reports of
flooding you can have often flash
flooding in our city no reports of flash
flooding
because the royal parks prudently closed
their parks we've also thankfully don't
have reports that we've had in previous
storms of you know trees falling on uh
people which can cause real uh harm
and sometimes loss of uh life because
there are a few people in their cars we
also are hearing stories about cars
being stuck as well and that's why
following the advice staying indoors
doesn't just make it less likely you'll
be injured
it makes it creates less work for first
responders and others as well